nul ne peut arrêter l'horloge du temps
elles sonnent aujourd'hui pour moi
l'heure du retrait lourd voire de jean
claude gaudin à marseille une page se
tourne pour le maire qui a su garder son
emprise pendant 25 ans sur la cité
phocéenne aux membres du conseil
municipal depuis 1965 jean claude gaudin
est élu maire en 1995 après deux échecs
en 83 et 89
[Musique]
voilà que la droite décroche marseille
deuxième ville de france
un mois après l'élection de jacques
chirac à la présidence de la république
jean claude gaudin est dans les petits
papiers du gouvernement il est nommé
ministre de la ville en novembre 95
effets de sa commune le marqueur de sa
politique
premier projet pour entamer la mutation
urbaine de marseille euroméditerranée
présenté en 1995 il se veut le cousin
marseillais de la défense à paris avec
des bureaux des logements et des
commerces
cela devrait permettre de redynamiser de
relance et de reconstituer tout le coeur
de marseille jean claude gaudin et
marseillais il aime marseille il fut
porte l'om
même le sol le maire passe aussi du
temps à paris occupée par son mandat de
ministre jusqu'en 1997 puis de sénateur
trop de distance selon ses détracteurs
critiques balayées d'un revers par
l'intéressé selon la politique
représente 95% de ma vie c'est ma
vocation
en 2001 alors qu'il est candidat à sa
succession 71% des marseillais se disent
satisfaits de leur maire son ambition
désormais faire de marseille la capitale
euro méditerranéenne en développant les
transports et la culture nous appuyant
sur un bilan
un bilan nous avons pu assainir les
finances en mille ans nous avons pu
étudier des grandes réalisations réélu
en 2001 en 2008 et en 2014
jean claude gaudin a transformé le
visage de marseille en tout cas une
partie comme le vieux-port piétonniser
et le mucem
la ville attire peu à peu entrepreneurs
touristes et nouveaux habitants
mais il ya aussi le revers de la
médaille l'endettement croissant de la
ville la fracture entre quartiers nord
et sud
un chômage supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
et ces dernières années l'insalubrité de
certaines écoles et certains quartiers
l'effondrement de deux immeubles de la
rue d'aubagne en 2010 ce qui compte
c'est que on trouve le moins de morts
possible mais nous pensons qu'il y en
aura après quatre mandats c'est la fin
de l'ère gaudin le maire a annoncé en
2010 est qu'il ne se présenterait pas à
80 ans pour la première fois depuis des
décennies
jean claude gaudin a glissé un autre
bulletin que celui à son nom
[Musique]